International Fencing Association was
warned this could happen the Ukrainian
team competing at the World
Championships said its athletes wouldn't
shake hands with athletes From Russia
with the two countries at War
when four-time world champion Olga
Harlan trounced her opponent Thursday
she extended her saber to tap blades
instead of a handshake that was what
fencers did during the pandemic her
opponent refused but it wasn't over and
a smirnova didn't leave she stayed on
the fencing pissed for more than 50
minutes smirnova demanded Harlan be
disqualified for not shaking hands it is
in the rules she eventually was we just
kept
Harlan calls Thursday a difficult but
important day says she was Guided by her
heart and that after a year and a half
of fighting a handshake with a Russian
athlete would have been wrong right now
they they heal people in my company
[Music]
now the refusal to shake hands has come
up in other sports the Ukrainian tennis
player lost the match at this year's
French Open to a Russian player and was
booed by the crowd For What was seen as
unsportsmanlike I don't know I want to
see people react to it in 10 years when
the war is over I think this they will
not feel really nice about what they did
now after her disqualification there was
support for Harlan the Ukrainian foreign
minister says she showed dignity while
NHL Hall of Famer Dominic kashuk says
she was put in an unfair position he's
calling on International Sports
federations and the international
Olympic Committee to ban Russian and
belarussian athletes
Ukrainian officials called for the
disqualification to be overturned if it
stood Harlan wouldn't be eligible to
compete at Team events in the world
championships and it would have
seriously hurt her chances to qualify
for next year's Olympics well neither
are going to be a problem the suspension
at the worlds has been lifted she can
compete and the head of the ioc a former
fencer himself went even further Thomas
Bach wrote to Harlan Friday saying even
if she doesn't have enough qualification
points they will reserve a spot for her
at the Paris Olympics
Mike Armstrong Global News